d'avoir fait d'avoir remplacé le lait
dans son café par une boisson végétale
est de plus en plus populaire l'offre de
produits se multiplient que ce soit au
petit café du coin dans les grandes
chaînes ou encore à l'épicerie le marché
des boissons végétales augmente
annuellement de 33% depuis cinq ans
quand vous avez apporté le pois chiche
le change nettement j'étais vraiment
surprise pas des produits qu'on connaît
c'est vraiment comme adore de ce qu'on
est habitué
alex est un des facteurs des baristas
avec son équipe il est pour nous une
trentaine de boissons végétales
plusieurs produits s'affiche comme étant
barista interne pour expliquer que la
boisson est idéal pour la préparation
d'un café c'est normal qu'une composante
marketé mais encore faut-il la valider
donc s'il y avait un saut barista parle
ici d'évaluer vraiment ce qu'on est
capable de travailler avec pour faire
par exemple une belle micro moss
cependant il y à des distinctions à
faire certains produits sont comparables
à de la crème à café que l'on ajoute
tout simplement
alors que d'autres sont utilisés
spécifiquement pour le moose âge genre
devront à quel point on a fait des
cadeaux pour tous les produits le corps
d'ado c'est un peu comme un bébé lattes
et qu'on l'utilisé environ deux ans
d'espresso raviront presque quatre ans
de boissons végétales
donc ça nous permet de voir si leur
produit ils y chrome os bien qui sont
les gars de travailler avec pour faire
des motifs puis moi pour moi c'est par
un portage veut toujours que le café à
l'intérieur du breuvage peut s'exprimer
comme il faut ce qu'on recherche c'est
une belle homogénéité
on suggère enfin température dosage et
techniques influence la fabrication de
la mousse le protocole est en place on
goûte et on note le meilleur résultat a
été obtenu avec les boissons de soya les
seuils en général même si c'était pas
instants au bout des mots sur leurs
meilleurs produits peu importe la
catégorie d'une boisson de soya va vous
faites avoir tout les ingrédients
nécessaires pour mousser parce qu'il
contient
des protéines et contient un peu d'huile
lamia l'austin et chercheuse elle étudie
les protéines végétales
elle nous explique le rôle des
ingrédients dans ces boissons la chimie
lorsqu'on lit mousse plus un produit par
container de protéines mieux il va
mousser ça c'est certain
si on rajoute une gomme ou un autre et
pis s'ils semblent c'est sûr que ça va
aider encore à maintenir la stabilité du
produit à faire un bon travail en terme
de messages belle mousse belle texture
rompu si c'est pas identifié barista que
plus de choses qui se séparent après
avec le café dans le cadre du barista ce
qu'on cherche est mou cela il faut
qu'elle soit stable
qu'est-ce qui fait cette stabilité ce
sont les protéines les lipides et joue
un rôle mais il en faut pas trop parce
que il faut maintenir un certain
équilibre dans la boisson
parce que si on met plus de lipides mais
à ce moment là on va rentrer la mousse
et les gommes c'est pour stabiliser au
fait de cette émulsion pour qu ils pas
justement de séparation ça donne aussi
une sorte de textures l'ajout de
vitamine peut aussi influencer par
exemple le calcium carbonate
il va également jouer un rôle pour lier
les protéines ensemble il va aussi
également apporté une couleur dont il
veut blanchir la boisson maintenant on
teste les boissons d'avoine et encore
mais me approuvé brest comptait vraiment
surpris parce que honnêtement il ya peu
la texture pour la micro must c'est
quand même très surprenant de voir ben
la cia qui effectivement la même marque
mais qui était pas mentionné le port a
couvé par statut beaucoup plus belle
réaction que celui-là lavoine qui est
entier barstad on s'est un peu dommage
parce qu'on croit pouvoir se fier le mot
barista n'est donc pas toujours un gage
de réussite si par exemple le produit se
dégrade avec le stockage où il est mal
entreposées il peut y avoir des
changements au niveau de la boisson qui
vont faire qu'il ne va pas mousse et
comme il aurait dû le faire
c'est vraiment tranché au couteau la
sacem axa sa s'est posé en cassant tout
de suite que c'est possible comme un
genre de flacq mike là tout comme s'ils
échouent mais vraiment bon tu
embaucherais belle texture juste parfait
avoir une très très grande gamme à la
base parce que tout le monde peut
trouver son compte dans l'avoine plus
que coco note même si steve antique
evanston n'y arrivait pas une texture
guigou et avait toujours toujours des
séparations de plus en plus on voit des
boissons à base de légumineuses dans le
marché autour des boissons de
légumineuses les poids lui c'est
intéressant parce que c'est une boisson
à base de pois chiches ou hong hao fait
utiliser la graine en entier le lait
pour nous c'est super bien mais au goût
des biens avec le café poids était quand
même surprenant parce que la mousse
était belle mais au goût via voce en
équilibre c'était amer et est peu
intéressant en fait faut aussi prendre
en compte est ce que le gic bonheur à
boire mon café là avec ce produit
[Musique]
on a même réussi à fait positif du tout
de textures ces engins qui reste très
liquides avec le café devient comme
gélatineux et vous n'avez pas réussi
avec celui là le tout au son c'est déjà
perceptible ça fait sens très aigu et
script dans la pression reste coincé
dans le lait ça va faire des grosses
grosses bulles qui vont disparaître
aussi rapidement par après les boissons
de noix de coco de riz de sarrasin de
chanvre de noix sont faibles en
protéines donc mousse - on obtient
davantage les shows qui peut apporter un
coup intéressant comme ici avec le riz
je trouve ça très bon et un côté très
cacao versa un même en textures un peu
lasse pas mon jeu comme surprise moi
personnellement mon mot coup de coeur
c'était un lait à base d'avoine les
produits d'avoine et de soya ont été les
boissons préférées de nos barista et
quatre se sont démarqués sur tous les
points en protéines végétales celle à
venir de plus en plus on va diversifier
la façon dont on consomme les protéines
végétales et les boissons c'est parmi
ceux là aussi
[Musique]